The new Nintendo Switch
game console hits stores
this weekend,
uh, giving gamers a new way
to ignore their loved ones
at home or on the go!
(cheering, applause)
I know, I'm very excited.
But crusty critics have been
slamming the Switch
for its limited roster
of game titles, like, uh,
1-2 Switch,
where you can milk a cow
and take care of a crying baby.
Um, listen, I think that's fine.
Finally, we have
the technology to simulate
being a Kentucky teen mom.
You guys wanted that.
Or Little Inferno...
Little Inferno,
where you can burn stuff
in a virtual fireplace.
Comedians, I want you to give us
some even more atypical
video games other than
the ones on the Switch.
I'm gonna put 60 second on
the clock, and begin. Natalie.
Call of Booty: Modern Dating.
Points. Lauren.
Microsoft Paint Drying.
Points. Pete.
Super Mario Batali Bros.
Points, yeah. Lauren.
Grand Theft Auto Zone
Waiting Area.
Yes, points. Very good.
Pete.
Star Fox News.
Yes, points. Natalie.
Gynecologist Lara Croft:
Womb Raider.
Ha! Very good.
Points. Pete Holmes.
Single Dragon.
Yes, points.
Winners don't use drugs.
Uh, Lauren Lapkus.
Call of Jury Duty.
Yes, points.
Natalie.
-Duck (bleep).
-(buzzer sounds)
(game over sound effect)
Wait, Duck (bleep)?